Hallo. Ja, ein wunderschönes Namen, bitte.
Guten Tag. Usta ist mein Name und ich möchte mit Ihnen über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen, aber zuerst brauche ich ein paar Personen an und kommen wir zu Ihren Beschwerden.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden? Ja, gerne.
Wie lautet Ihr Name? Mein Name ist Johannes Weber. Johannes Weber.
Ich bin im Vornamen. Genau.
Und ich möchte Sie bitte den Nachnamen buchstabieren.
Wie Wilfried, Emil, Bertha, Emil, Richard.
Ja, Herr Weber. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 44 Jahre alt. Und wann sind Sie 44? Ja.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren? Am 1. Februar 1979.
1979.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit? Ich wiege 75 Kilogramm.
Und wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 1 Meter 81 groß.
80 groß. Ja, Herr Weber, was wird Sie uns?
Und zur Folge ist, seit 4 Tagen habe ich starke Schmerzen in meinem Nacken, linksseitig, und die Schmerzen sind zunehmend, die ziehen in meinen rechten Arm hinein.
Die Schmerzen sind bewegungsabhängig. Wenn ich meinen Kopf nach links drehe, tut es mehr weh.
Das ist die Schmerzzunahme. Eine Schmerzunahme bei links drehen meines Kopfes.
Ja, okay. Alles klar. Wir haben die Schmerzen begonnen, oder plötzlich?
Ja, also ein Tag vorher habe ich bei einem Freund beim Umzug geholfen.
Ja. Und dann am nächsten Tag bin ich mit Schmerzen aufgewacht, am nächsten Morgen.
Dann habe ich ein bisschen Schmerzen gehabt, und die Schmerzen sind jetzt immer mehr geworden.
Haben Sie sehr schwer Gegenstände gehoben, oder?
Ja, alles. Schwerwe, leichte Kartons, Möbel, Waschmaschine, schon einige.
Aber der Umzug war gestern, ne?
Nee, der Umzug war vor 5 Tagen. Seit 4 Tagen habe ich Schmerzen, und ein Tag vorher, vor diesen 4 Tagen, hatte ich beim Umzug geholfen.
Schmerzen strahlen nur im rechten Arm hinein?
Ja, in meinem rechten Arm bis zu meinen rechten Daumen.
Ja, rechten Daumen. Okay.
Ja, bis zu meinen rechten Daumen. Die Schmerzen sind zunehmend ziehend, und es ist bewegungsabhängig.
Okay. Sind die Schmerzen, haben Sie die gleiche Geschwerbe früher gehabt, oder zum ersten Mal?
Ja, früher habe ich abends auch mal Nackenschmerzen gehabt, aber ohne Ausstrahlung in meinem Arm.
Ja, okay. Also, 1-2 Mal vor einigen Jahren, also ganz früher.
Ja, okay. Haben Sie vielmal Herr Weber?
Wie nochmal?
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber, nein, habe ich keinen.
Okay. Haben Sie Übelkeit?
Übelkeit habe ich nicht.
Müssten Sie...ebrechen?
Nein.
Ja, okay. Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, durch die Schmerzen kann ich weniger schlafen, ja. Muss ich ein paar Mal nachts aufwachen wegen den Schmerzen.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Ne, habe ich keine.
Okay. Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Ab und zu, ja. Im Hinterkopfbereich.
Ja. Okay.
Nun würde ich mit Ihnen über Ihre Vorerkrankungen sprechen, aber davor möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, wo Sie gesagt haben, ob ich Kopfschmerzen habe, habe ich auch manchmal ein bisschen schwindel.
Ja, schwindel, okay.
Also, wenn die Schmerzen sehr stark sind, habe ich Kopfschmerzen und schwindel.
Ist der Schwindel sehr plötzlich aufgetreten?
Nein, also schmerzabhängig.
Ja, okay. Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen oder Kopfschmerzen in rechten Armen oder Nakaschenerzen?
Im Nakaschenerzen?
Im anderen Bereich, nein, in meinem Daumen habe ich Kopfschmerzen.
Mein Daumen, der ist ein bisschen pelzig, sind Kopfschmerzen.
Ja, okay.
Gab es in Ihrer Vergangenheit irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
In meiner Vergangenheit Vorerkrankungen, was meinen Sie damit?
Zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit oder Bandvorfall im Rücken.
Bandscheibenvorfall, meinen Sie?
Ja, Bandscheibenvorfall.
Okay, nee, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Ja, okay. Haben Sie irgendwelche Medikationen eingenommen?
Ja, seit 4 Tagen nehme ich bei Bedarf Ibuprofen ein, 600 Milligramm.
600 Milligramm Ibuprofen bei Bedarf?
Und was noch?
Ne, nur das nehme ich ein.
Nur Ibuprofen wegen der Makaschenmerzen.
Genau, richtig.
Ich würde nach Ihrer Familie vorgeschickt fragen und lehnen die Eltern noch Herr Weber?
Ja, meine Eltern leben noch.
Okay, sehr Gott sei Dank.
Und leiden Ihr Vater und Ihre Mutter an chronische Erkrankungen?
Was sind, was meinen Sie damit?
Ja, meine Mutter hat eine Zuckererkrankung, nimmt Tabletten deswegen.
Was ist alles?
Ja, so weit ich das weiß.
Haben Sie Gechiwista?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Okay.
Ist er gesund?
Ja.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden, Herr Weber?
Ja, in meiner Jugend wurde ich mal operiert.
Da wurde mein Blindamen entfernt.
Ist die Operation komplikationslos verläuft?
Sobald mich erinnern kann, kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass es schlecht war.
Haben Sie gesagt mit 18?
Nein, in meiner Jugend mit 15 Jahren.
Wurden Sie aus einem anderen Grund operiert?
Aus?
Aus einem anderen Grund operiert.
Das Blindamen wurde, ob ich da, oder wurde etwas anderes noch operiert?
Ja, was noch?
Also zusätzlich.
Ja, zusätzlich.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Nichts besonders, nein.
Ich war gleich.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig vor?
Nicht wirklich, nein.
Wie ist die Appetit, Herr Weber?
Normal, gut und auch völlig.
Haben Sie bestimmte Allergien?
Allergien, ja, gegen Nüsse habe ich Allergien.
Wie öffnet sich Nüsseallergien?
Wenn ich Nüsse esse, dann habe ich wirklich Atemnot.
Atemnot, okay.
Brauchen Sie, Herr Weber?
Brauchen, nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, gelegentlich, bei Heier.
Was trinken Sie und wie oft?
Wie oft? Ja, gelegentlich, also regelmäßig ist es nicht.
Was ich trinke, meistens trinke ich ein Bier.
Ja, okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie das nicht persönlich, das ist eine Rückenfrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Oh, Drogen, nein.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie Drogen geschrieben wird.
Das ist eine Rückenfrage.
Haben Sie Kinder, Herr Weber?
Ja.
Wie viel?
Ein Sohn.
Ist der gesund?
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Sind Sie zuheiratet?
Ja.
Und wohnen Sie oder lieben Sie mit Ihrer Familie zusammen?
Ja, genau.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Busfahrer.
Busfahrer.
Das ist gut.
Ja, ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen.
Sie haben seit vier Tagen zunehmende, ziehende,
natten Schmerzen in die rechten Arme.
Links, links, links.
Links und strahlen.
Die Schmerzen strahlen die Rechten.
Nein, alles links.
Alles links.
Okay.
Und die Schmerzen sind bewegungsabhängig?
Die sind bewegungsabhängig.
Okay, das war meine Frage.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, Herr Weber?
Ja.
Wie geht es jetzt weiter, Herr Doktor?
Ja, ich möchte jetzt erklären, was wir machen wollen.
Ich möchte Sie körperlich unterrufen.
Und danach möchte ich, würde ich Nackenschmerzen,
Röntgen veranlassen.
Und gegebenenfalls eine
MRT zu anlassen.
Okay.
Ja, und,
könnten Sie die Schmerzen aushalten
vor der Untersuchung, oder können Sie
die Schmerzen aushalten?
Ja, ich halte die Schmerzen aus, ja.
Hauptsache, sie helfen mir.
Die Schmerzen sind bewegungsabhängig.
Okay.
Hab'n Kollege Nanderefragen.
Wie geht es jetzt mit der Schmerzen?
Von 0 bis 10.
Von 0 bis 10?
Ja, ich würde sagen 7.
Welcher Handbein ist es von der Arbeit, Herr Weber?
Ich bin Busfahrer, ich bin in beiden Armen. Aber ich bin selber Rechtshänder.
Sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Wegen dem Nachhinschmerzen jetzt aktuell nicht, nein, Sie sind meine erste Arzt.
Sie haben gesagt, die Übeprofen sind 600 mg eingeladen.
Welche Verbesserung bewirkt die Medikamente?
Die Medikamente, eine leichte Linderung ist schon da.
Wenn ich die nehme, dann sind die Schmerzen weniger, so 3, 4 ungefähr.
Die Schmerzmittel, also Übeprofen, bewirkt eine Linderung.
Die Schmerzen immer da, sie sind nur Kopfbewegung.
Sie sind immer da, aber die sind schlimmer, wenn ich meinen Kopf nach links drehe.
Sie haben gesagt, krippen.
Welche Seite?
Mein linker Daumen.
Mein linker Daumen ist pelzig, ein bisschen komisches Gefühl.
Pelzig, kommt vom Pelz, Kürk.
Sie haben gesagt, schwindeln.
Wenn ich starke Kopfschmerzen, also wenn ich die Nackenschmerzen zunehme,
dann kriege ich starke Kopfschmerzen.
Dabei ist ab und zu mal, dass es mir schwindelig ist.
Das dreht sich alles so ein bisschen bei starkem Schmerz.
Wie viel Minuten dauert die Schwindel?
Wenn ich zum Beispiel mein Kopf nach links gucke, weil ich etwas sehen möchte,
dann kommt der starke Schmerz.
Durch den schmacken Schmerz, das dauert so ungefähr 4 Minuten.
Haben Sie sehr störung, auch störung?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nicht sehr störung, habe ich nicht.
Timnitus, was bedeutet auf Deutsch?
Timnitus, dauert das Geräusch, haben Sie Geräusche?
Ja, Geräusche.
Ich habe nichts, kein Problem damit.
Können wir anfangen?
Ja, ja. Hallo Herr Oberath.
Wir haben heute einen neuen Patientin.
Ich möchte über ihn berichten.
Ich habe ihn seitwünftig.
Ja, natürlich. Schießen Sie mal los.
Ja. Mein Patientin heißt Johannes Weber.
Er ist 44 Jahre alt und erste Februar 1979 geboren.
Er wiegt zurzeit 75 kg schwer.
Er ist 1,81 Meter groß.
Er ist ein 44-jähriger Patient, der sich bei uns seit 4 Tagen beschädt,
zunehmend nach Schmerzen vorgestellt hat.
Die Schmerzen sind bewegungsabhängig.
Auf einer Schmerzskala hatten die Schmerzen bei 6.
Im Laufe der Zeit hatten die Schmerzen sich immer verschlechtert.
Und der Patientin gibt an, dass er Schlafschütterung wegen der Schmerzen hat.
Er klagte über Schwindel und ab und zu Kopfschmerzen.
Er ist wegen der Schmerzen, der mit 15
und er hat Nüsseallergie und er äußert sich mit Atemlos.
Er ist nicht raucher und er trinkt gelegenlich Bier.
Die Frage nach Gewichtsverlust und Appetitlosigkeit wurde von dem Patientin verleinert.
Er hat einen Sohn, der gesund ist und ist verheiratet und wohnt mit ihrer Familie.
Er arbeitet als Busfahrer.
Der Vater des Patienten hat Bluthochdruck.
Die Mutter des Patienten hat Zuckerkrankheit.
Ich glaube, diese Krankheit ist nicht verbunden mit diesem Fall.
Ich würde gerne den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Ich würde ein Nackenregion in zwei Eben veranlassen.
Ich würde gerne den Nackenregion in zwei Eben veranlassen.
Ich würde trotzdem sagen, dass Röntgenhws in zwei Eben veranlösen.
Röntgen aufnahmene Aufnahme.
Ich glaube, es ist schwer, den Bandscheibenvorfall zu sehen.
Es ist schwer, den Bandscheibenvorfall zu sehen.
Warum machen wir eine Röntgenaufnahme?
Warum machen wir eine Servikal-Vibelsäule?
Man kann etwas ausschließen.
Wir sollten einen Pneumotorax ausschließen.
Wenn man Schmerzausstarrungen links hat, kann man andere Probleme haben.
Aber es geht jetzt zu Zeit.
Man kann bestimmte Sachen im Röntgen sehen.
Im Röntgen können wir im Knochen sehen.
Man kann aber sehen, wie hoch der Bandscheibenfach ist.
Man kann auch sagen, ob der Knöcher eine Degeneration hat.
Wir haben Röntgen gemacht, der sieht gut aus.
Ich würde gerne eine MRT von der Servikalregion.
Sie können auch abkürzen.
Als Therapeute empfehle ich dem Patienten, dass ich Schmerz und Schmerzmittel einnehmen.
Welche Schmerzmittel würden Sie als erstes geben?
Was ist das?
Das ist eine Entzündungshema.
Wenn es nicht reicht, kann man noch zu Nauvalgien oder Parasamol.
Die erste Therapeute wurde durch die Orale Einnahme von nicht stitulärer Antiromatik.
Wir haben eine Therapie, aber wir haben noch nicht über die Diagnose gesprochen.
Im MRT sehen wir einen Bandscheinvorfall C560.
Wie würde bei Ihnen die Diagnose heißen?
Das ist eine Servikale Bandscheinvorfall.
Das ist eine spezielle Diagnose.
Das ist eine Servikobrachialgie.
Das ist eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Das könnte eine Neuropathie sein.
Das ist eine Neuropathie.
Das ist eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Was noch?
Man empfiehlt immer eine konservative Therapie.
Ich glaube, es ist eine Stadion der MRT.
Wenn man eine Stadion der MRT hat,
dann würde man empfehlen,
dass die Stadion vom Bandschreiben verfallen.
Eigentlich geht es um die Klinik.
Wenn es eine Kraftverlust gibt, empfiehlt man eine Operation.
Paris, das ist wichtig.
Was ist der Unterschied?
Das ist eine Stadion der MRT.